I saw my dad cheating over Facebook I
don't have the guts to tell my mom
because I don't want me and my siblings
to end up having a broken family I
caught my mom cheating on my dad
so I keyed her car and flagged her tires
I'm not sure how our relationship will
piece back together after that I found
out my dad was cheating on my mom and
told her about it now they're getting a
divorce and I know it's not my fault but
I feel like it is I found my mom
cheating on my dad with one of his
friends five years ago my dad still
doesn't know when it kills me every day
for not telling him when I was little I
caught my dad cheating on my mom I never
told anyone because I thought I could
convince myself it was just a nightmare
I had I caught my dad cheating on my mom
he paid me $250 to keep my mouth shut
but I told her anyway and kept the money
I cut my mom cheating on my dad and she
has no idea why I'm shutting down I
caught my dad cheating with my aunt when
I was 17 now I'm 22 with no relationship
whatsoever and a fear of meeting a guy
like him I feel like I'm too broken to
love and to be loved I saw my dad
cheating and he put his condom in my
room and told my mom it was me having
sex I was 12
Oh